joe biden campaigns in georgia as
democrats push further to the left
former republicans declare they will be
taking over the party now and the
culture wars continue as a san francisco
high school dumps abraham lincoln as its
namesake i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get all the news and there is
an awful lot of news to get to first let
me tell you about an amazing
holiday gift i'm talking about the most
delicious of all holiday gifts i am
talking of course about the meat
omaha steaks beef i'm talking about
their
amazing deluxe grillers assortment here
is what it features you ready
four top sirloins eight boneless chicken
breasts four omaha six burgers eight
gourmet jumbo franks eight individual
scalloped potatoes eight caramel apple
tartlets
and one jar of signature seasoning i
know that their meat is amazing because
they sent me a steak a kosher steak like
a year ago
this thing is juicy it is mouth-watering
it is perfectly aged it was perfectly
preserved when they sent it to me i mean
it is just it is
the easiest thing to grill it's terrific
terrific stuff right now you get that
mouth-watering deluxe griller's
assortment
plus four free burgers and a free
digital meat thermometer an exclusive
price available only to my listeners
head on over to omahastakes.com
enter code shapiro into the search bar
omaha steaks is not just steak
it is a guaranteed fantastic gift a safe
way to share the joy of the season don't
forget
when you order the deluxe griller's
assortment you'll also get four free
omaha steaks burgers and a free digital
meat thermometer with my coach shapiro
at omahasteaks.com that is a deal you're
not going to find
anywhere else again it's all backed by
100 money back guarantee as well
visit omahasteaks.com type shapiro and
that search bar to shop the best gourmet
gifts of the season i mean
whoever opens up that gift is going to
be so happy that day my goodness
omahasteaks.com type shapiro in that
search bar
to search for the best possible gifts
okay so
joe biden was down in georgia yesterday
campaigning
for raphael warnock and john ossoff
both of whom are radical john ossoff is
a trust fund socialist
and rafael warnock is an actual crazy
socialist
leftist marxist insane person rafael
warnock is a person
who's like hot on castro hot on louis
farrakhan hot on linda sarsour
everybody who sucks he loves immensely
and this is somebody that joe biden
desperately wants to be in the united
states senate because you see here's the
thing
for all the talk about how the
republicans have broadened the overton
window to allow people in who shouldn't
be
the democrats have never ever narrowed
the overton window on their left
there's nobody on the left who is too
far left for the democratic party it
just does not exist
the republicans have cast out from among
them people like representative steve
king
who was replaced in the last election
cycle in a primary that seat now belongs
to a different republican fienstra
but you don't see the same thing from
the democrats you just don't
the republicans looked at roy moore in
alabama they're like no we're not going
to do that
and doug jones who's a democrat ended up
representing alabama as a senator which
is insane because alabama is probably
the most red state
in america for democrats however you get
raphael warnock
up there praising louis farrakhan and
talking about the wonders of jeremiah
wright
and joe biden's like you know what we
need this guy in the senate really
really need this guy in the center but
don't worry
i'm an old-fashioned moderate a super
old-fashioned moderate so
biden showed up in georgia and uh and
started talking about why you need
all of these people in the senate he
said
about the the georgian voters that you
voted in record numbers in order to
improve the lives of every georgian and
you voted as if your life depended on it
which by the way is the worst line i
hate that line so much
your life does not depend on your vote
in the united states of america if your
life depends on your vote in the united
states of america you don't live in a
free country anymore
it truly it is that simple maybe your
lifestyle depends on your vote that's
fair
maybe the decisions you make in your
life are impacted by your vote i think
that's true
but your life itself depends on your
vote if that is true you are no longer
living in a constitutional republic you
are living under threat
of extermination like the citizens of
hong kong for example
but this kind of stuff is just it's
egregious it's egregious
and then he says guess what you're going
to have to do it again so this is
captain i'm going to take down the
temperature here
joe biden i'm going to take down the
temperature also if you vote or die
like literally if you don't vote then my
political opponents will probably look
to kill you
i mean that's that's wild wild stuff
okay so joe biden
then mocked the the republican senators
from the state lefler and perdue
here he was yesterday going after left
lauren purdue both of whom have
challenged the
state election results in georgia
there's still an outstanding lawsuit in
georgia
over voter irregularity and voter fraud
it is the sole outstanding serious
lawsuit
by team trump with regard to the
possibility of voter fraud and voter
irregularity and that will still be
adjudicated in court but here was
biden going after kelly lefler and david
perdue
you know who didn't stand by you know
did nothing while trump texas and others
were trying to wipe out every single one
of the almost 5 million votes
you had cast here in georgia november
your two republican senators they stood
by
in fact your two republican senators
fully embraced
what texans were telling the supreme
court they fully embraced
nullifying nearly five million georgia
votes
just a quick note for joe biden
according to polling statistics
apparently a majority of georgians are
concerned about that election status
and believe that the election actually
did not go the way that um that it was
certified as going so
i'm not sure how appealing that message
is going to be joe biden is not exactly
the guy that you bring into a rally to
get people revved up
right he's the guy you hide in the
basement and then you make him
president-elect
because he was in the basement like the
more he gets out the less people like
him the more he is out there in the
public eye more people like oh this one
really of all the humans they the
american public i think
looks at joe biden in much the same way
that uh jason bateman
looked at michael cherry's girlfriend on
arrested development it's like her
her really her
yeah i think and the more you see a bite
the more you see that i mean yesterday
even while he was
in the middle of rallying he looked like
he was going to keel over and here was
joe biden calling john ossoff
john ortof this is after declaring that
a person he selected for his own cabinet
was named xavier bakera
his name is xavier becerra here is slow
old joe biden
home for your next united states
senators john orson
yeah orsoff who i don't know
that one that guy or that's every other
good championship museum
there's kamala harris in the background
just grinning ear to ear like the joker
and here's uh here's joe biden also
sounding unwell
same rally the lives of every georgian
still depend on what you're doing yes
you still need to vote as if your life
depends on it because it does
and guess what you don't have to wait
till january 5th to vote
you can vote starting now early vote has
begun
there's no no one that's not one reason
here
why you should wait to vote you hear his
voice pretty hoarse there
and joe biden there as a man on the
brink of death let me tell you your life
depends on this
taster joe food taster okay well one of
biden's other messages here aside from
you're gonna die if you
vote for my political opponents in
georgia one of those other messages is
time to unite guys
remember this is this is the same
nonsense that barack obama did that
barack obama
would constantly talk about how we
needed to we need to unify you get
behind me
unify as a nation by agreeing with mine
also if you don't agree with me you're a
better clinger
probably will rise just a little bit
just a little bit like a lot but a
little bit but mostly but a little
a little racist and now you got joe
biden doing the same routine
right so here was joe biden yesterday
saying he looks forward to working with
mitch mcconnell the senate majority
leader
sure you do joe i had a good
conversation with mitch mcconnell day
he talked to him i called him to thank
him for the congratulations
told him although we disagree on a lot
of things those things we can work
together on
we've always been stable on one another
and
we agreed we get together sooner than
later
and i'm looking forward to working with
them okay so
there he is captain unity well there i
have some unfortunate news for captain
unity
it turns out that his own deputy
campaign manager um
said a thing today that undercuts that
message of unity in rather dramatic
fashion we'll get to that in just
one moment first let us talk about the
greatest
food on plan i'm talking waffles okay
waffles yeah man
okay so there is this product it is
called the presto stuffer stuffed waffle
maker
and let me tell you over the weekend i
broke this thing out and i used it with
my kids it is just spectacular you pour
the batter in you put whatever stuffing
you want
in the middle of the waffle you put some
more batter in you flip it it cooks for
like seven eight minutes
and you have the greatest stuffed waffle
in history
we put in a bunch of peanut butter cups
oh my god it was it was a dessert waffle
it was unbelievable
things incredibly easy to use it makes
delicious waffles every single time it
is great
for pretty much everything sweet or
savory you can make it with chicken
the same way that you can make it with
candy the way that we did you can also
do it for keto diet so it doesn't have
to be completely
delicious and decadent you can also do
keto diets right you can make no or low
carb batters you make stuff with eggs or
chicken or cheese
you make burgers cream cheese veggies
and it's great for all of those things
the stuffer is easy to use it works with
most any batter not just waffle mixes
cake muffin brownie mixes both boxed and
from scratch you just pour in the batter
you add the stuffing you fill with more
batter you close the cover you flip it
and then you're done and the tongs are
built in so you just pick it up put it
on the plate you're good to go it is
delicious okay and it's family fun my
kids helped me out doing this
it was a blast they enjoyed it go to
www.stuffler.com
click the buy now and then the add to
cart button enter promo code ben to get
off again that is stuffler.com promo
code ben after
you add to cart this is an amazing
awesome product go check it out right
now stuffler.com promo code ben
after you add to the cart for a special
deal okay so
captain unity over here right i can't
wait to unify with mitch mcconnell also
also daily wire hank berrien reporting
joe biden's 2020 campaign manager jen
o'malley dillon who is now as
prospective deputy chief of staff
ripped republicans in an interview
saying she believed in unity but added
quote
i'm not saying they're not a bunch of
furs
yeah that's unifying i can feel the
warmth rolling off of you in waves there
jen
it sounds like you want to get together
and make the country a better place also
joe biden says that if you vote for
republicans then you might die
and also you're a bunch of efforts yes i
can i can feel
us all can't you feel this all coming
together it feels like the era of
division that began of course with trump
is now over and we are back to the era
of unity under barack obama that never
existed under barack obama didn't exist
under george w
bush didn't exist under bill clinton but
but it's definitely going to exist now
and the only way it's going to exist is
of course you
agree with joe biden that's the way that
this works because
if you believe if you truly believe that
joe biden is going to pursue anything
like a moderate agenda
he he is not he's not going to pursue a
moderate agenda he's just going to not
be as threatening in mean
and appearance as other democrats are
because he appears as though
he is on the verge of the next life okay
but that does not mean that he is not
going to pursue agenda items that run
directly contrary
to many long-held principles by the
american right
and by many americans who are not of the
right here is jen o'malley dylan's
full comment in glamour magazine which
again it's just hilarious to me the
glamour magazine is doing interviews
with people like jen o'malley dylan and
it just shows the bias in the media
maggie haberman over at the new york
times tweeted out this morning something
about a member
of joe biden's staff that that member of
the staff was talking about how she was
a mother and
and meg and maggie haberman tweeted out
it is pretty impressive and still rare
for women in politics to talk about
their pride and mothering it's like oh
my god
every single major republican woman of
the last administration was a mom
and they all talked about being a mom
like all of them none of them were
featured in magazines
they were all i mean sarah huckabee
sanders was a mom was getting tossed out
of like a restaurant with her family
and you jerks in the media were sharing
it anyway here is what jen o'malley
dylan had to say
i also think as in love compromise is a
good thing the atmosphere in the world
now is like oh if you compromise you
don't believe in something no it's
i believe in it so much i'm going to
work to find a path we can both go down
together
that feels to me like the heart of
relationships and love and success
across
the board the president's elect was able
to connect with people over this sense
of unity
in the primary people would mock him
like you think you can work with
republicans
i'm not saying they're not a bunch of
efforts mitch mcconnell is terrible
but this sense that you couldn't wish
for that you couldn't wish for this
bipartisan ideal he rejected that so
in other words we wish we could
compromise but the people across the
table
are efforts but we want to compromise
and so we get credit for the intention
right so it's it's like if if you bring
flowers to your horrible horrible spouse
who you're about to divorce right you
get credit for the bringing of the
flowers even if you then proceed to call
her
a um a very very bad word good good job
good job everybody team team biden
really unifying stuff
meanwhile joe biden is in fact pursuing
controversial policies controversial
picks so
biden is talking specifically about how
he wants to
use covid policy in order to tackle
racial and ethnic
inequalities ooh now that sounds like
exciting stuff this is something they've
been talking about for a while here
is that joe biden sees kovid as another
way of cramming down a particular
viewpoint
on the universe right there's a lot of
talk even in
his early coveted press conferences
after the election he was
he was hosting like a racial and
diversity coordinator and the idea is
that america
it's gaps in terms of racial death rates
those have to do with america's historic
legacy of racism and how terrible
america is and all this
so now according to the washington post
biden is doubling down
on that biden wants to continue to push
divisive policy in the face of covet now
it seems to me that when you are talking
about covet policy the first thing that
you should be doing
is focusing in specifically on fighting
the health problem
and we should focus in on people as
individuals who require care
not as members of groups who are quote
unquote historically victimized
the notion that that in order for you to
achieve
actual good health outcomes you have to
also pursue quote unquote social justice
rejiggering
of basic expectations is is pretty
ridiculous on its face
unfortunately that is something that joe
biden has already said that he is going
to pursue also
he is filling out his cabinet now and
who is who's he choosing
he's choosing you know unifying figures
like pete booty judge
so he chose pete booty judge as his
transportation secretary
so i said before it feels like basically
joe biden just has like a list of names
and then he has a list of positions
and he puts the list of positions up on
the dartboard and then he picks a name
and just throws the dart at the
dartboard and wherever the art comes
down
this is who will serve in that position
so it's like dennis mcdonough oh yeah i
remember
dennis pacquiaon and the obama
administration good guy john is just
dreaming
and and you know let's let's figure
let's let's find out let's find a place
for
for old dentist veterans affairs
veterans affairs
and somebody's like joe he's not a
veteran he doesn't know anything about
veterans affairs he doesn't know anyone
in the military
it's okay i threw the dart it's too late
dart's done
all right pete booty judge oh yeah i
love love pete pete's good guy good good
young
good young buck pete like my son i'm a
great great
let's find a transportation secretary
for good old people
why is he transportation secretary what
exactly are the
what is his expertise in transportation
as it turns out he has no
expertise in transportation politico
notes buddha judge's landing spot comes
as a surprise
given his thin transportation policy
resume
also gotta love this love that the media
are now calling booty chad she'd be the
first openly gay cabinet secretary
so richard grinnell was the ambassador
to germany and was
and was cabinet level position so they
are now
sort of tailoring this title so that
they can say that booty judges the first
even though
rick grinnell already was an openly gay
man serving in a high position in the
trump administration
but uh but politico points out that oh
yeah he uh he has no
transportation policy resume originally
he wanted to serve his ambassador to the
united nations which would have been
awful
and um so he went from mayor of south
bend to
the transportation secretary for no
reason at all
he will head to washington to take
responsibility for nearly 55 000
employees first of all
honestly just ban half of these
departments disband them
an 87 billion dollar budget and more
than a dozen administrations overseeing
the nation's aerospace highway system
pipeline safety
and more sounds great guys
biden said in the announcement jobs
infrastructure equity
climate all come together at the d.o.t
the site of some of our most ambitious
plans
to build back better i trust mayor pete
to lead this work with focus decency and
bold vision
he'll bring people together to get big
things
so good times he's going to be over
there um at
the transportation department there's
only one problem there's only one
problem
black activist warns against his
selection saying he and other long-time
biden allies rumored for the spot have a
poor record of working with communities
of color
two black community leaders from south
bend council member henry davis jr
and local blm leader jordan geiger both
of whom have criticized booty judge's
record throughout his presidential
primary campaign
mobilized in response to reports who's
under consideration davis said
he did a really bad job for this
community and my district in particular
bus lines have been shut down and cut
off
in one of the poorest census tracks in
the city geiger said he has no history
of working with black-owned businesses
hurting black communities is not worth
the price of doing a political favor for
pete booty judge just because he
endorsed biden's campaign
in the primary but that's all that that
really
matters you know all that really matters
in the end is that p booty judge is
somebody
that uh that biden wants to pass along
the position to and transportation
secretary will do as well as any by the
way
also worth noting in 2019 the
south bend tribune again the man was the
mayor of a city of 100 000 people
a hundred thousand people is again that
is a that is a
relatively small city 100 000 people and
that guy's going to be transportation
secretary and he couldn't even fix the
potholes there
according to the south bend tribune many
residents felt the city had quote the
worst pothole situation
in the state the tribune reported in
2018 is according to fox news that
potholes at the time
were the worst area repair shops had
seen in over 10 years
lines of vehicles reportedly awaited
repair for pothole damages every day
it's the worst i've ever seen said rich
ferrara junior service manager at rick's
autumn road 66 in south bend
though the state allows motorists to
file claims for damage caused by
potholes it's unclear how many claims
and how many
how many file claims and how many claims
are actually processed
in 2019 domino's pizza stepped in
offering south bend a 5 000
paving for pizza grant to fill in
potholes
so well done everybody by the way booty
judge's successor
ran on a platform of preparing the
potholes
make that guy secretary of
transportation makes perfect sense
perfect sense guys alrighty we'll get
some more of this in just one second
because it turns out that captain unity
over here is not super unified
as you would have suspected but first
let us talk about the fact that you
don't trust your social media companies
nor should you
they have made overt decisions on what
sort of material you should and should
not see they have downgraded material
that cuts against the democrats they
have upgraded material that is in favor
of democrats they've prevented people
from speaking freely so why would you
grant them access to your data so they
can monetize it and then
use your data to make money and then
prevent you from seeing the stuff you
want to see
instead why not hide your own data use
express vpn the big problem with tech
companies they not only censor what you
read they track what you do online
they'll track what you're searching for
the videos you watch everything you
click they use that data to serve you
ads they can match your activity to your
offline identity using your device's
unique ip address
when i use expressvpn tech companies
can't see my ip address at all
my identity is masked and anonymized by
a secure vpn server plus
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
data to protect you from hackers and
internet bad guys if that sounds
complicated it is not
you download it very quick with one
click you are now protected
so why give the tech companies access to
your most important data and then have
them turn around and sell it off
it's time to take back your privacy
expressvpn.com ben
visit my special link you'll get an
extra three months of expressvpn service
for free
who doesn't like to save money right
expressvpn.compressvpn.com
to protect your data today and it's also
worth remembering that mayor pete again
one of these unifying unifying figures
he started the campaign
as a guy who said basically that i'm not
going to look down my nose
at people on the other side of the aisle
and he finished his campaign as pastor
pete a man lecturing you
the traditional christian on why his
version of christianity in which
same-sex marriage and abortion were
sacraments
why his christianity was the right
version of christianity flashback to
he said christians will face a reckoning
on religion this is captain unity over
here on msnbc
just about a year ago for as long as
there has been faith
and as long as there has been politics
there have been different understandings
on the right thing to do and how these
things fit together but for the the
party
and the movement known for beating other
people on the head
with their faith or their interpretation
of their faith
it makes no sense to will literally vote
to take
food away from the hungry to
essentially be practicing the very thing
that not just a christian scriptural
tradition but so many others
uh tell us we're not supposed to do in
terms of harming
other people um and i do think there's
going to be a reckoning
i mean honestly his his religious
viewpoint which is basically all of my
leftist priors ought to be confirmed by
religion and if you disagree you're a
bad christian
he was the only theocrat in the race so
far as i could tell and donald trump
certainly wasn't a theocrat but pete
booty judge definitely definitely was
and he was very divisive
on that end by the way the things that
religion requires are that you ignore
all democratic social policy and pretend
that it's good and also
worry seriously like a lot about global
warming here he was around that same
time
talking about how god will not let us
off the hook on global warming question
god gonna let us off the hook on you
know the murder of a million unborn
children in the womb every year in the
united states how about that do you
think god's like super hot on that one
pete here he was back in 2019
environmental stewardship isn't just
about taking care of the planet it's
taking care of our neighbor we're
supposed to love our neighbor as
ourselves
and the biggest problem with climate
change isn't just it's going to hurt the
planet i mean in some way shape or form
the planet's still going to be here
it's that we are hurting people people
who are alive right now
and people who will be born in the
future the way i see it
i don't imagine that god's going to let
us off the hook
for abusing future generations any more
uh then you would be off the hook for
harming somebody right next to you and
with climate change we're doing both i
mean god
i mean god is not going to let us off
the hook if we don't take care of
climate change because that hurts both
future generations and people who are
here right now
now do abortion now do abortion
i mean that literally is harming future
generations and people who are here
right now
literally by killing them but you know
what
it's okay unity cabinet guys super
unifying speaking of super unifying
joe biden also wants to pick jennifer
granholm for energy secretary
now what exactly is her experience with
energy considering that she's the former
governor
of michigan not much she's a
quote-unquote long-time champion of
renewable energy development ooh she
likes windmills
that's so exciting good times also a
unity pick
flashback august 25 2012 quote
republican convention delayed due to
hurricane
isaac i guess god has ways to shut that
whole thing down
yeah good times with jennifer granholm
who also has hashtagged moscow mitch
consistently for the last
year and a half and then again all that
matters for the press
is what diversity box they fill so here
is the new york times reporting on
jennifer granholm who is
a radical lefty here is what the new
york times reports if confirmed grand
home 61 will be the second woman after
hazel o'leary
who served under president bill clinton
to lead the vast department which
oversees the us
nuclear weapons complex as well as 17
national laboratories in a wide range of
energy research and development
initiatives
oh my god you mean she'll be the second
woman after the famed hazel o'leary
wow mind blown so historic
so people who judge will be the first
cabinet level secretary
who's gay except for rick grinnell who
is a cabinet level guy
who is gay in the trump and she will be
the second woman
to lead the famed energy department
after hazel o'leary
the second most famous o'leary after
well third most famous because it goes
like mrs o'leary who's cowboy in chicago
and then troy o'leary the former right
fielder for the red sox and then hazel
o'leary
so that's exciting stuff says the new
york times
miss granholm is widely credited during
her two terms as michigan governor with
steering her state through a recession
and working with the obama
administration on a 2009 bailout of the
automobile industry that included clean
energy investments and incentives for
car makers to invest in technologies
like battery storage oh you mean
she presided over the the continued
degradation of the car industry in
michigan to the point where
manufacturing in michigan sank to such a
level that donald trump was elected in
2016.
yeah that was good stuff also she gave a
ted talk in 2011
on investing in alternative energy
resources so that's exciting
we can expect her to pour a bunch of
money into a useless technologies that
will likely not succeed
what what what a unit so much unity
going to happen guys so much unity
you efforts we'll get some more of this
in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you need energy i need energy these days
my kids keep me up at all hours of the
night and yet i have to come in here
every day and provide you
with the greatest podcast and radio show
in the nation which means i have to
go through just a lot a lot a lot of
energy and that means i need
black rifle coffee black rifle coffee
company ceo and founder evan hafer
he started the business after over 20
years in the us army as an infantryman
special forces soldier cia contractor
evan founded black rifle in 2014 along
with former army ranger matt best as the
combination of two passions developing
premium fresh roasted coffee
and honoring and supporting those who
serve on the front lines
black rifle is a fantastic company
they've donated over 45 000 pounds of
coffee
over 1 million cups of coffee to
soldiers deployed overseas law
enforcement officers
wildland firefighters on the west coast
and medical workers during coveting
response just in 2020
alone and their coffee happens to be
fantastic if you need a boost during the
day that tastes great
i'm telling you you got to have black
rifle coffee if you want to support the
cause go to blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro today get 20 off coffee apparel
and gear as well as 20
off your first month of the coffee club
that is blackriflecoffee.com for 20
off coffee apparel and gear again 20 off
your first month
of the coffee club go check them out
right now blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro okay well if you thought okay
well you know these are just cabinet
secretary so who
who really cares i mean they're cabinets
don't worry the moderates will still be
in charge
the the media are so itching for joe
biden to be off the stage they are so
itching for him to be gone thomas
friedman has a piece in the new york
times today
titled kamala harris deserves a more
important job
so here's the thing she's
the vice president-elect which means
that there is only one more important
job
right it's not like it's not like there
are tons of them out there
right so she needs a more important
let's let's think real hard about what
that more important job could be
thomas get a food taster that is the
worst job in america
being joe biden's food taster that
short-lived job as it turns out
that is a temp job not because you do it
and then you're fired but because you do
it then you die
if you're a joe biden's food taster says
thomas friedman i was speaking recently
to matt dunn founder
of the center on rural innovation which
promotes digital economic development in
small town america he was telling me
about a vermont community near his home
with a great public library
he could drive by on any sunday the
parking lot would be full he said there
was just one problem the library was
closed
on sundays the parking lot was full of
cars with kids doing their homework and
adults doing their office work
using the wireless connectivity spilling
out of the empty building because their
rural homes lacked high speed
broadband that is why i want to talk
today about vice president-elect kamal
harris
harris is too smart and energetic to be
just the vice president a position with
few official responsibilities
i'd love to see president-elect joe
biden give her a more important job his
de facto secretary of rural development
in charge of closing the opportunity gap
the connectivity gap the learning gap
the startup gap
the anger and alienation gap between
rural america and the rest
yes i'm sure kamala harris former
senator from california and a.g of
california
of california is going to be the person
to tackle the gap
between rural and urban in terms of
alienation and anger
also i love the idea that she is well
qualified for anything beyond her job
she wasn't even qualified to be senator
from california
she's a terrible senator awful she was a
terrible ag
and then she was plucked from obscurity
to be
this this vice presidential candidate
solely on the basis of her race and her
and her sex that is not me saying that
that was joe biden saying that
okay so don't she deserves a more
important job doesn't mean
deserve the job she she's going to get
let's say come on come on but they they
are itching to get biden off the stage i
mean my my goodness
my goodness and the the war on you
efforts it is just beginning it is just
beginning and by the way
the media are gonna push it from every
possible angle so couple angles they are
pushing it from
today if you are a conservative if
you're somebody who thought about voting
for trump or did vote for trump
or you just don't mirror the prevailing
values of joe biden and the democratic
party
well then there's two angles the media
are pushing one angle which is there's
gonna be a new republican party and it's
gonna be taken over
by by the best the best available
republicans you know the people who
didn't vote for trump and who held out
and who hated trump and who yelled at
him a lot
those people are gonna be the people who
take over the republican party
and so today the new york times is
pushing an op-ed from evan mcmuffin
sorry it's mcmullen mcmullen sorry about
that
former cia operations officer and chief
policy director for the house republican
conference
he ran against trump in 2016 and earned
one half of one vote
he has a piece in the new york times
saying if the republican party doesn't
shape up
we will challenge it note to evan
mcmuffin
you did try to challenge that in 2016.
and respect you tried it it didn't go
great for you so i'm wondering what you
think your base of support is
in taking over the republican party
post-trump presidency like what exactly
is your
is your base of support to come in and
scream at everybody who voted for trump
that they're a bad person is that is
that because that's kind of what you
were doing for like years on end and as
somebody who didn't vote for trump in
and did vote for trump in 2020 it's
off-putting it's silly
okay but don't worry you know who's
gonna lead the republican party in the
future it's gonna be people apparently
according to the new york times
like evan mcmullen so says evan mcmullen
in his op-ed
what's next for republicans who reject
their party's attempts to incinerate the
constitution
in the service of one man's
authoritarian power grabs where is our
home
now the answer is we must develop an
intellectual and political home for now
outside of any party from there
we can continue working with other
americans to defeat mr trump's heirs
help
offer unifying leadership to the country
and if the republican party continues on
its current path
launch a party to challenge it directly
yeah good luck good luck gang
i hope that you've enjoyed your time in
the semi spotlight
i hope you've enjoyed the strange new
respect that republicans receive
shortly after yelling at republicans
if you want to get a headline today if
you're a an obscure republican announced
that you're no longer republican you'll
be on msnbc
instantly and then within five minutes
they'll be declaring your racist sexist
bigot homophobe again if it turns out
you're a conservative so good luck with
that speaking of which steve schmidt
who was he his respon he is is um
he's now re-registering as a democrat
which makes sense he's been helping to
elect democrats since 2008 when he ran
john mccain's campaign so make sense now
he's gonna do it formally
he said yesterday he was registering as
a democrat well don't let the door hit
you on the way out buddy
i spent 29 years as a republican
i've spent two and a half as an
independent and later this afternoon
i will register as a member of the
democratic party
wow and i'm doing that what a journey
because in america today
it's only the democratic party which is
the oldest political party in the world
that stands for the ideas and ideals of
american liberty
oh my god oh my you're right
it's the only the party that says that
the government should run every aspect
of your life
and be involved in every aspect of your
life that stands for liberty
this is by the way that's him talking to
david proof former obama staffer and i
love ploof just fluffing him right there
oh wow wow that's a big announcement
steve schmidt
who's been completely irrelevant to all
conservatives and republicans for
literally
several years yes yes huge move
okay guys don't worry they're not taking
over the republican party but you're
going to see
the democrats try to prop up figures
like this meanwhile
your illustrious media bettors they're
going to continue just
sneering at you and treating you like
garbage and it doesn't matter
how conciliatory you are they will still
treat you like garbage
trump didn't come out at an hour gang
and whatever happens with trump in the
future
it ain't the end of the backlash that is
only just beginning in this country okay
the backlash is just beginning
got a question and we do all access
every night that's haleyware for
subscribers
and uh and so i was hanging out with
some subscribers last night and somebody
asked me how i can remain optimistic in
the face of the fact that democrats have
taken over so many of our major
institutions
and in the face of the electoral college
vote yesterday and what i said is i
think the backlash is on the beginning
i think that the democrats have
succeeded in taking over the highest
levels of our institutions from
hollywood to the media to social media
and i think that's a problem the fact is
republicans
should hold the senate republicans over
performed in the house
republicans over perform in state houses
across the country despite all of that
imagine if republicans were to actually
fight back on the cultural level
fight back against the institutional
dominance of the left the backlash is
only beginning the left is pushing too
far
they're pushing too far and we'll get to
the media in just one second because
again
you keep saying that you want unity and
then you spit in the eye of anyone who
even reaches across the aisle it's
pretty impressive
we'll get to that in just one moment
first let us talk
and let us talk about your sleep quality
so
last night baby woke me up 1 30 a.m
wanted to
have a bottle so i dutifully got out of
bed got her the bottle went back to bed
now i'm not somebody who falls back to
sleep easily at night one time up i'm
kind of
up which is bad if it's 1 30 in the
morning but not so anymore because i
have a helix sleep mattress that was
made just
for me helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress you know will be perfect for
the way
you sleep everybody is unique helix
knows that they have several mattress
models to choose from
they've got soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot even a helix plus mattress
for plus size folks
we've been getting unboxing videos from
so many of you who have found the helix
sleep experience
just magical it is it's cool it comes in
the mail you open it up inflates right
in front of you it's good to go just go
to helixsleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life they've got a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but indeed you
will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com go check them out right
now
up to 200 bucks off all mattress orders
two free pillows for our listeners
helixsleep.com
ben to get a mattress made just for you
okay
we're gonna get to the media and then to
some of the social war stuff the culture
war stuff that continues to animate the
country because trump
won in 2016 thanks to the culture wars
it wasn't about economics i really don't
think it was
it wasn't about the rural urban divide
it was about a culture divide
between what charles murray once called
the new upper class
and the new lower class what he meant
was a cultural upper crust
of college graduates who have decided to
speak their own language versus
everybody else we'll get to that in just
a moment first
on monday december 21st the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw will
soon be available exclusively at
dailywire.com
originally released as an audio podcast
for apple and spotify what we saw is
available now to watch
as well as listen to on apple daily wire
apple tv or roku app
or at dailywire.com it's a docuseries
full docu series that is awesome looking
it is beautifully edited
it takes a detailed look at the apollo
11 mission to land a man on the moon
the culmination of a heated decades-long
space race between cold war rivals the
united states and the soviet union the
podcast explores one of america's
greatest accomplishments through the
eyes of the millions of americans who
lived through it it's a dramatically
inspiring story and it is fantastic to
watch with your loved one
great with your kids over the holiday
break especially we're now living in
what maybe a second space age go check
out apollo 11 what we saw and right now
get it for 20
off with code watch when you become an
insider or above member at dailywire.com
subscribe make sure to download our
apple tv or roku app to get all of our
content on your big screen
including our podcast and special live
streams that is dailywire.com
subscribe to get 20 off your membership
with codewatch and
access to all of our new and existing
content you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
so in line with the theme that the
democrats and the media want you to
unite with the democrats who efforts
uh the the media have been pushing you
know quote unquote moderate republicans
and anti-trump republicans as the
replacement
for the mainstream republican party also
on the other hand they are they are
basically just spitting in the eyes
of republicans so excellent example
yesterday a couple of excellent examples
from
esteemed journalists the objective media
okay so yesterday mitch mcconnell the
senate majority leader went on the floor
of the senate and he acknowledged
that joe biden was the president-elect
because the electoral college had voted
for him so this is true
here is here is mitch mcconnell doing
just that this would be a conciliatory
move
from mitch mcconnell right i mean he's
doing what he's supposed to do he's
congratulating the guy who just won the
electoral college vote
many millions of us had hoped the
presidential election
would yield a different result
but our system of government has
processes
to determine who will be sworn in on
january the 20th
the electoral college has spoken
so today i want to congratulate
president-elect joe biden
the president-elect is no stranger to
the senate
he's devoted himself to public service
for many years
okay so now that was that was mcconnell
trying to be gracious
naturally that means that the democrats
are going to immediately spit on him
that's it because that's the way this
our politics works is you why won't you
just acknowledge the reality why won't
you just say what we want you to say and
then he says what they want him to say
like because he's an
ass like what uh hold on so here is
kamala harris
sitting one million feet from uh from
who's this barber that's not barbara
walters i can't remember who that is is
that angry mitchell
a little hard in any case here is uh
here is
kamala harris sitting on the other side
of the planet from whoever is
interviewing her
saying that it wouldn't better if
mcconnell had said it earlier why the
electoral college only voted
on monday here was kamala harris being a
jerk
mitch mcconnell and joe biden have
spoken
he has acknowledged that he is the
president-elect
how important do you think that is i
think it's critically important
i applaud mitch mcconnell for for
talking to joe biden today you know it
would have been better if it were
earlier but
it happened and that's what's most
important and so let's move forward
okay so obviously that was robin roberts
now speaking in that clip
yes it's gracious i wish he had done it
earlier now we can move forward
except that nobody really wants to move
forward they just want to yell and then
you get anderson cooper again
a member of our esteemed journalistic
establishment serving up a slow clap for
mcconnell mcconnell does what he is
supposed to do according to the media
which is he's supposed to acknowledge
that biden has now won the electoral
college and call him president-elect and
all that
so mcconnell does it and the media
greets that with well you know
he should have done it what a jerk what
why would anyone try to please you
people there is no purpose
none here is anderson cooper another
objective journalist
so six weeks dozens of court cases two
supreme court rejections
one fascist rally four stabbings
countless threats against election
officials who are just doing their jobs
and more than 200 million dollars in
deceptive trump fundraising since the
election
a slow clap everyone for senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
after all it's not like he said anything
that wasn't obvious the saturday
after the election five weeks ago when
news organizations called the race for
president-elect biden
except for how there's a legal process
and uh he wasn't president-elect biden
until the electoral college voted except
for that
i mean technically mcconnell's a little
early because he's not actually
president-elect until the house ratifies
the vote on january 6th
but it doesn't matter doesn't matter so
kaylee mcinanny yesterday was at the
white house and she was quite properly
calling out the media for the fact that
they are
damned liars for the fact that they
covered up the hunter biden story for
weeks approaching the election
and then immediately after the election
they started covering the hunter biden
story because now it was safe
for the groundhog to emerge from his
hidey hole so here was kaylee mcinerney
shellacking the press
yesterday on october 15th you had a new
york times headline that said
trump said to be warned that he was
being given
russian disinformation over hunter biden
now december 10th just a few months
later new york times headline
investigation of hunter biden is likely
to hang over biden as he takes
office washington post on october 16th
the headline read the truth behind the
hunter biden non-scandal
now you have the washington post
headline that says this hunter biden tax
probe examining chinese business deals
so that all happens to be true and the
media gets super mad
super duper duper mad so jim acosta
and no one is going to fall into
obscurity faster than jim acosta right
and this guy's had his moment because
his entire moment was pretending to be
sam donaldson or dan rather during the
reagan era or he's going to speak truth
to power well now what happens when
speaking truth to power means that he
actually goes up and gives joe biden a
shoulder massage so jim acosta who loves
jim acosta he starts yelling at kaylee
mcinning you talk about media
disinformation your
your disinformation you this whole court
is out of water he's doing al pacino and
injustice for all
like this ridiculous person this
ridiculous ridiculous person here's jim
acosta's final gasp
good for those who covered what was the
story all along and not
russia disinformation isn't it critical
for you to accuse others of
disinformation when you spread it every
day
you oh you're going to accuse others of
disinformation when you say it every day
it was like oh slay queen
on twitter the entire me oh look at jim
acosta that's excellent so just a note
she's walking out of the room when he
says this thing that means he's a hero
when peter ducey of fox news asks joe
biden about when he knew his son was
under investigation
and biden turns back to him and says
thanks for the congratulations
then that's just biden also slaying
queen so you may notice that there's a
bit of a bias
in how exactly we approach reporters who
ask questions after people
leave the podium then you get don lemon
objective journalism
saying yeah girl bye girl wow i mean
when i think
of like truly great journalists when i
think of television voices of authority
it goes like you know edward r murrow
walter cronkite and the girl bye guy
does the president acknowledge that joe
biden is the president-elect
does he have any plans to invite him
here to the white house um the president
is still involved in ongoing litigation
related to the election uh yesterday's
vote was one step in the constitutional
process so
i will leave that to him and refer you
to the campaign for more on that
litigation the president
again is pursuing ongoing litigation
would refer you to the campaign for
further
still pursuing on ongoing litigation at
the moment
did you know she also works for the girl
by
i mean there's another girl bye
bye bye
so so much disinformation coming from
the podium it's just
it's every day it's like comes out reads
propaganda
talks about the what the media is doing
criticizes the media
this is what you should be covering
i think we got this you used to sit here
on the set with us
i think we got it when you sat here with
us you thought we had it
you were happy to be here but now we
don't know what we're doing
girl bye the press are only for the
press they're not for telling you the
truth they are for the press right
the reason don lemon is upset is how
dare you how dare you madam
suggest that we provide disinformation
as we did for several lawyers
about russia and about white supremacism
inside the trump administration
and all that girl bye like what what
slay again slay just amazing amazing
slaying going on
from the members of our media because
the bottom line is it's about scorn for
you
it's about scoring for anyone who
disagrees with them
because here's the thing you have to
understand about members of the media
and members of again what charles murray
has called the new upper class the new
upper class
is united not merely by the fact that
they have college degrees and not merely
by the fact
that they work in service industries and
they get to go to their jobs well you
cannot go to your job during covet
that's not all that unifies them what
unifies them is a particular language
they have these linguistic signifiers
they speak sentences that don't make
sense to normal human beings because
they're not meant to make sense to
normal human beings like a secret code
right
you can tell because they're the people
who will put their pronouns in their
bios
they're the same people who will use
drop terms like systemic and
institutional racism without any actual
explanation of what they mean
people who will say that anti-racism
means to discriminate on the basis of
race
it's it's those kinds of folks folks who
use a completely different set of
language
who look down on you this is a new upper
class they're what was once turned by
james burnham the managerial elite but
they have created their own case right
they've created their own case and this
this case
looks down on you they score on you and
they wish to ramrod their positions on
life down to you
by the way never living by those same
positions one of the hilarious things
about the new
upper class as charles murray refers to
it and his book coming apart
one of the things about the new upper
class is that they are statistically
speaking
more likely to be married they are more
likely to have a job
they are more likely to live almost
conservative lifestyles but they are the
least likely
to suggest that anybody else ought to do
those things
in fact they see their virtue in
precisely that they see their virtue
in this soft bigotry of low expectations
they extend to the rest of society
and in their all-powerful god of
tolerance
meaning that they are going to tolerate
anybody who agrees with them and
not tolerate anybody who disagrees with
them and this brings us to the culture
wars
okay so the culture wars are ongoing the
left is not going to stop here it's not
going to stop
everybody thinks that politics is about
politics politics is no longer about
politics because politics stopped being
about politics
the minute the politics started entering
into every arena of american life
now politics is about the culture
because any time you engage with the
culture you cannot escape politics
literally any time right at your job you
cannot escape
i get letters every single day many of
them
letters calls texts every single day
from people who say
i'm interviewing for a job and people
are asking me to pair a woke prop again
what do i do
i'm in a social situation and family
members are being jerks about my
politics what do i do
i'm in college and i just want to have a
cadre of friends
but i can't mention that i'm a
conservative what do i do this happens
all the time and the backlash is coming
because the left has basically declared
itself a religious cult
the radical left has and they've taken
over the auspices of the mainstream left
and
all institutional channels and you can
see it happening in real time and the
backlash is going to be extraordinary
okay everybody on the left thinks the
backlash was trump the backlash was not
trump trump was the beginning of the
backlash he is certainly not the end of
the backlash
get ready for the backlash so the left
is just going to continue pushing
because they feel their oats right now
right they think that they can they can
push and push and push and nobody will
ever push back on them
this is why you see for example andrew
cuomo banning the sale
of confederate flags now i'm not a
confederate flag fan
i've been saying this for quite a while
right i understand both sides of the
argument i understand
folks who look at the confederate flag
and see it as a symbol of slavery
because in fact was a symbol of slavery
during the confederacy and i see
the perspective of southerners who say
this is southern heritage and i don't
think of it as a symbol of slavery
because my grandpa flew it over his tank
the battle of the bulge
i get that too i'm not a fan of the
confederate flag generally because
it is open to interpretation that way
however it is an aspect of free speech
in america
that one you can fly the confederate
flag and two
it's just an aspect of a free speech
culture that if somebody's flying a
confederate flag you probably shouldn't
make the assumption that they're a
baseline rote racist okay but andrew
cuomo is not doing that so andrew cuomo
just signed a bill banning the sale of
confederate flags in his state
he signed a bill into law aiming at
banning the sale of hate symbols such as
the confederate flag
or the swastika on state property even
while admitting the new edict might
clash with the first amendment and be
struck down as
unconstitutional so
he he doesn't care about the first
amendment you see it's all about the
virtue signaling to all of his lefty
friends first of all how many
like really how many confederate flags
in swastikas are being sold on state
property in new york
how many two like it's a completely
unnecessary piece of legislation
but the goal here is to signify that
andrew cuomo is against
bad things and you if you don't like
andrew cuomo you are in favor of the bad
things and you
if you think the first amendment
protects activity you don't necessarily
like it's not that you're pro-freedom
it's that you're pro-evil
right so cuomo said this country faces a
pervasive growing attitude of
intolerance and hate whatever what i
have referred to in the body politic
as an american cancer by limiting the
display and sale of the confederate flag
nazi swastika and other symbols of
hatred from being displayed or sold on
state property including the state
fairgrounds this will help safeguard new
yorkers from the fear installing effects
of these abhorrent
symbols fear installing effects he says
well you know we have to be careful
about the first amendment
but you know that's that's the secondary
concern because of course
for andrew cuomo it is all about the
virtue signaling associated with his
particular perspective it is not about
preserving
american freedoms okay and these sorts
of stories are blanketing
the country okay it's not just
legislators like andrew cuomo or
executives like andrew cuomo
and the fact is that much softer
versions of this can be found everywhere
it's it's it's astonishing how how much
this ideology of the
of the woke class has infused every area
of american life and truly incredible
okay so
this is the question that i get the most
and it is now coming up everywhere okay
the cultural dominance of the left
is not being challenged and when the
right fights back it's gonna be
it's gonna be vicious and it's gonna be
brutal and it ought to be okay so here's
a letter from a person who will remain
unnamed now he says i'm a daily listener
i wanted to thank you for the work you
do
today i had my seventh interview with a
large company out of the liberal city i
won't name the city
they recently opened an office here the
interview was with their co
to be honest i felt like i had the job
if i was getting this far into the
process
unfortunately i'm now hesitating with my
excitement for the future with this
company
the second question in my interview was
quote what have i done
to personally and professionally end
systemic racism
i answered the question the best i could
i'm not sure how anyone can give
examples for this
she went on to tell me she has hired
someone from google to come in and end
systemic racism
within the company tomorrow i'll be
delivering a one-hour powerpoint
presentation for a panel of people for
my final interview
this is truly uncharted territory for
america i really don't know where we're
heading
needless to say my presentation and
narrative for my final interview has
changed direction
the cultural cram down that is happening
here when you're being asked
on job interviews just normal job enter
you're not working for some sort of
501c3 a normal job interview you're
being asked how you're fighting to end
systemic racism in the united states
which by the way
is not possible as an individual
according to abram kennedy and robin
deangelo both in order to quote unquote
end systemic racism
as a white person you're supposed to
both sit down and shut up and also
mirror the beliefs of robin deangelo and
ibram kendy and fight against the system
itself
my answer if somebody said how are you
fighting systemic racism
what i would say is according to robin
and angelo and abram kennedy the only
way to fight systemic racism is to tear
down the capitalist system so my plan
is to enter your company and completely
wreck it that is my plan to end systemic
racism
your company is part of the problem and
then dare them not to hire you
and then call them racist if they don't
hire you right because that is the
backwards logic that is now being
applied and it really is not of course
about what they think you're going to do
or that they want you to quote unquote
and systemic racism they don't even know
what that means
it is all about do you speak the
language do you speak the language and
the language is becoming ever more
extreme
ever more radical and ever more
difficult to understand
take for example this brilliant twitter
exchange this is one of my favorite
twitter exchanges
of all time so there is a feminist named
liz plank
a canadian author and award-winning
journalist who used to be a political
correspondent
at vox.com so she was very very angry
about the fact that so many people
agreed with people like me or joseph
epstein or tucker carlson that dr jill
biden is not a real doctor because she's
not a real doctor she has an edd in
education
from university of delaware joy
okay and so liz planck wanted to say it
was misogynist to point out that this
is not an actual like being a doctor
thing
it's it's it's non-feminist it does does
not matter by the way
that a huge percentage of people in
medical schools i believe a majority now
people in medical schools are women
so that doesn't matter it is sexist to
say
that the term doctor should really only
be applied to medical doctors so she
tweeted out
liz planck msc oh msc what what
what an absolutely incredible degree
that is
wow i i mean just shocking so she
tweeted out
that she she tweeted out it's a masters
of science degree
okay she tweeted out can every woman who
sees this change
sees this change their handles to
reflect their credentials
and she started seeing people put out
like their master's degrees
we're all very impressed this is all
part of that new upper class i'm talking
about people who identify by their
credentials
because it gives them cachet in the
circles in which they travel it's the
reason by the way that dr joe biden
wants to call herself doctor jo
and she's openly said this is that she
wanted more respect and so she started
calling herself dr jill and got that edd
in education and so one woman wrote back
as so liz blank said can every woman who
sees this change their handles to
reflect their credentials
and there's one this one woman wrote
back quite properly if i dropped out of
high school
can you recommend some initials to put
at the end of my name that will make me
worth something as a person
which is just a devastating rebuttal and
because the fact is that you should not
be characterized
as like a special person based on your
degree right this is just basic
credentialism
so liz plank wrote this back this is
just it's a wonderful entree
into the bizarro linguistic world of the
social justice warrior left and the new
upper class here's what
liz plank says quote trying to correct
the systemic and historical erasure of
women's contributions and
accomplishments doesn't
and shouldn't preclude us from also
fighting against the myth
of meritocracy wow
man is that's margo bargle right there
my goodness that is gobbledygook
now i can decode that for you if you'd
like so here's what she means she means
that if we don't pay attention to the
fact that liz blank is in msc
first of all i don't pay attention to
dudes who have an msc i certainly don't
pay attention to dudes who have an edd
i mean like that's a degree that fewer
people have heard of
then like if you say that somebody has
an edd to somebody they'll ask if they
have erectile dysfunction
it is that uncommon of a degree in any
case liz planck
is making two separate contentions one
she says that with that you have to put
the title at the end of your name
in order to prevent the historical
erasure of women's accomplishments
because if we don't call dr jill dr jill
this means that we're erasing her
accomplishments also
that should not preclude us from making
the separate and mutually exclusive
argument that the meritocracy is bad
so you cannot have this both ways if you
are talking about
accomplishments and contributions and
the need for a meritocracy
she says that we should also fight
against the myth of a meritocracy
because there is no meritocracy nor
could there be a meritocracy
okay if all this sounds like ridiculous
crap that's because it is ridiculous
crap but the point is that you are
supposed to pledge fealty to the
ridiculous crap and you are supposed to
speak the language of the ridiculous
crap in order to be accepted
into the woke circles of higher power
the
here's the problem the more radical that
circle of higher power becomes
the more americans are going to say you
know i don't want to be in your circle i
don't like your circle your circle's
dumb
so we're just going to stay out here and
you know what we're not going to pay
attention to the institutions you
control
we're going to move away from those
institutions we're going to build our
own there are more of us than there are
of you
we're not going to remain silent and if
you want to not hire me because i
couldn't answer your dumb question about
how i'm ending systemic racism in
america because i'm working at a bank or
something
then guess what i'll just go work at a
different bank guess what i won't work
with you
and have fun hiring a bunch of degree
holders
in woke social justice who feel that it
is by necessity their job to make your
business less efficient
because capitalism is the source of all
evil like really go for it
the way this has infused so many
portions of american life is going to
drive a backlash like you've never seen
here another example yesterday the new
york teachers union
new york's new york city teachers union
passed a black lives matter at school
resolution
they called for many things among the
many things that it called for
was quote black villages we are
committed to disrupting
the western prescribed nuclear family
structure requirement by supporting each
other as extended families and villages
that collectively care for one another
and especially our children
to the degree that mothers parents and
children are comfortable
so um that's right the new york city
teachers union
passed a black lives matter at school
resolution calling for the disruption of
the nuclear family
which makes perfect sense i mean if you
really want to make lives better for
black kids what you definitely need to
do is disrupt the nuclear family it's
been
it's worked wonders for black children
all across america
the elevation of single motherhood from
a 20 phenomenon in 1960
to a to a plus 70 phenomenon in 2020 has
been
absolutely excellent particularly for
young black boys well done
black lives matter crowd well done woke
social justice warriors yes what is
deeply necessary is to undermine
the fundamental family structure that
provides boys particularly with some
form of guidance
solid stuff right there really really
good stuff
and meanwhile in social justice warrior
land also a san francisco
high school has decided to rename itself
so san francisco is according to the uk
daily mail
decided to rename abraham lincoln high
school
and you're saying yourself wait isn't
abraham lincoln the president who uh
freed their lives
like civil war guy abraham lincoln like
not some other abraham lincoln i've
never heard of
oh yeah no no it's that abraham lincoln
but he's bad now san francisco is going
to rename
abraham lincoln high school because the
former president did not demonstrate
that black lives
mattered to him
i'm pretty sure they did considering
that he fought a civil war to end
slavery
that seems like a pretty good indicator
that somebody is kind of concerned about
black lives that he didn't want them to
remain enslaved
but apparently not good enough for the
san francisco woke
also the lococrats at the san francisco
unified school district
they've decided not only to rename the
abraham lincoln high school
because of his treatment of indigenous
peoples through the 1862 homestead act
and the pacific railway act
but also but also they are going to
rename
a bunch of other schools 44 schools will
be renamed
what are these schools george washington
will be renamed of course because george
washington was a slave holder
yes of course george washington was also
the father of the country but you know
you know the people in san francisco
they're better than he is than he was as
a person they just they
if they had lived in 1790 they would
have been better people than george
washington they're the greatest people
who have ever lived
herbert hoover high school is going to
be renamed
that's going to be renamed for some
unspecified reason that i can't exactly
explain
thomas edison will be renamed because
thomas edison was bad
and also dianne feinstein's name will be
stripped
from the dianne feinstein elementary
school for once allowing the confederate
flag to fly
outside city hall so dianne feinstein is
not woken up for this game
it's going to be fun i am looking
forward to in like 10 years when they
have to strip barack obama's name off of
things
because when he started his presidency
he wasn't pro same-sex marriage
like that's going to be fun that will be
enjoyable so they're stripping all names
off all things this is just marxism
it is just commie bullcrap but again
this earns you
you have now seen history through the
eyes of the oppressed
and this means that we have to take away
all the good things that have happened
in history and we have to
smear them through the mud and this is
going to make the world a better place
speak the language speak and repeat and
if you don't speak
and repeat this means that you're a bad
person
this means that you cannot be among us
the woke
the cadre of the of the brilliant
moral arbiters of the future of the
united states speak and repeat
and by the way you can be just as
sensitive as you want but if you make a
mistake they'll come after you so
here is an example shawn mendes okay so
shawn mendes
uh is uh apparently some sort of a
singer i i
as you well know i am not a follower of
today's pop culture other than being a
platinum award-winning rap artist
um shawn mendes i had to apologize to
sam smith so sam smith is a singer he is
a gay man
he also recently declared himself gender
fluid and said he wanted
to use the terms they and them to refer
to him
which is silly because he's an
individual human being also
he has not changed his biology he
remains a gay man nonetheless he
being a gender fluid being right being a
a magical unicorn
sam smith was now owed an apology by by
sean mendes why because shawn mendes
committed the egregious sin of saying he
now i know most americans
most people around the world actually
look at that and they're like what now
and that a dude
and yes that is a dude sam smith
but if you say that he is a dude he gets
very angry apparently
and if you wish to be welcomed into the
halls of social power you have to abide
by the graces of the language
so sean mendes put out a statement oh
sam smith i'm so sorry for referring
to fs to you as a he for your jingle
bell introduction
it absolutely slipped my mind won't
happen again no apostrophe
sending you so much love also you
absolutely are one of the funniest
people
i've ever met two hearts wow i mean that
is an egregious sin when you call a man
he
not even a man who identifies as a woman
just a man who identifies as a they
as a genderless being when you call him
he
grave grave sin these are our cultural
arbiters i can't
the backlash to this stuff is going to
be overwhelming and it should be
overwhelming it is bad
okay it is it is not good for the
country it is
it is not good for the future of reason
and decency
it's bad stuff alrighty later today
we'll be back for two additional hours
of content
while you wait head on over to the matt
wall show today at 1 30 pm eastern over
at dailywire.com he's talking more about
this insane story from the san francisco
high schools taking
abe lincoln's name off of school because
he didn't show black lives matter to him
also he's talking about that trans
activist we talked about yesterday who
advocated puberty blockers
for all children yes if it feels like
society's collapsing around you don't
worry don't worry it's not going to
it's the left contributing to its own
collapse we'll get some more of this a
little bit later in the day otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
mitch mcconnell calls joe biden
president-elect
cnn complains that melania read a book
to sick kids in a hospital
and california governor gavin newsom
faces a serious recall effort check it
out on the michael knowles show